BIGELOW BLOOM BONTA BROUGH
CALDERON CARRILLO CHAU DEEP
EGGMAN FONG HERE GABRIEL GARCIA
MAIENSCHEIN. OBERNOLTE.
PETRIE-NORRIS YEAH QUIRK YEAH
RIVAS. RIGHT THIS IS AB NINE
TWENTY ON PARENTS PETRIE-NORRIS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THE PURPOSE
EIGHTY. NINE TWENTY IS TO
PROTECT STATIONS ARE IN THE
COUNTRY. PARKER YEAH I HAVE A
SHATTERPROOF NATION LIKE
NONPROFIT ALSO. IT WAS
WONDERFUL THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS. CONFERENCE. THANK
YOU DOES NOT SUPPORTERS SEEN
NONE ANY OPPOSITION. IN AN
APARTMENT FINANCE. MINAJ ON
INTO THE PROGRAM FINANCE THE
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME
ALTHOUGH THE NUMBER OF LTE SELF
INTEREST IS. PROGRAMS I KNOW
IT'S ONLY A HUNDRED THIRTY
LONG. FIND OUT. IF I CAN HELP.
IN ADDITION OF OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. DOLLARS. AND
SOMETHING LIKE FOR ME TO
SUPPORT THE CALL. THE ABILITY
TO CALL. THANK YOU LONGEST
PRESENTATION THE NIGHT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. ONE OF LIKE
IT'S OUT ON A ROLL CALL THANK
YOU AND THAT. IS THE IN